vous le savez pierre jean chalon sont le
mec d'affaires contre il est
régulièrement au centre de critiques
puisque hier vous avez vu l'histoire
avec line renaud et aujourd'hui il est
accusé d' imposture erwan lamonde michou
[Musique]
[Rires]
michou je l'aimé de ouf voilà
j'adorais michou il m'a aimée crimes et
tous les ans une petite carte pour me
souhaiter bonne année michou jeu même
fort et l'amande michou erwan donc
accuse pierre jean salençon de mentir en
permanence nous allons vous sortez un
jeu est régulièrement invitée pour
réagir en tant que proche de michou sur
les plateaux sauf que selon certains
proches de michou il n'en est rien et
selon eux ils ne connaissent même pas me
croire je le connaissais même pas on
vous révélera la lettre écrite par
l'amant de michou et roanne à
pierre-jean chalencon alors est ce que
ça vous choque regardait ce que france 2
doit s'en séparer regardez après s'être
fait remarquer pour avoir copieusement
insulté line renaud sur les réseaux
sociaux
voilà que pierre-jean chalencon
l'excentrique collectionneurs de
napoléon et chroniqueur de l'émission à
faire conclut paix une nouvelle fois
polémique
cette fois ci c'est dans une lettre
rédigée par le dernier compagnon de
michou que pierre-jean chalencon est
accusé d' imposture
c'est notamment suite à ses déclarations
sur la vie intime de michou dans
l'émission héritage présenté par jean
marc morandini peu le chroniqueur s'est
fait épingler dans son courrier erwan
toularastel n'y va pas par quatre
chemins il commence non seulement vous
intervenez dans l'émission héritage en
vous faisant passer comme un ami de
michou depuis plusieurs années et en ce
qui me concerne vivent avec michou
depuis 20 ans je ne vous ai jamais vues
auprès de lui vous êtes apparu dans son
entourage que depuis quelques mois et
vous prétendez être le gardien de sa
volonté mais de quel droit
vos propos sont d'une indécence total
votre égo et votre suffisance font tache
sur sa personnalité
contactée par nos équipes pierre-jean
chalencon réfute ces accusations il
maintient qu'il avait bel et bien une
vraie proximité avec michou alors les
révélations sur pierre jean chalands
sont accusés d' imposture choquer ou pas
chaud pied
[Musique]
alors que sur demande à bernard il
valait plus que jamais seul bernard
franchement vous êtes le spécialiste
l'ipl al adha ou non mardi d'abord moi
je n'étais pas proche de michao je
l'aimé beaucoup effectivement je
connaissais très bien et roanne a
effectivement plus de 20 ans avec lui
bien sûr maintenant il y avait une
question d'héritage surtout mais erwan
par exemple qu a vécu 20 ans avec lui
n'était pas marié avec michou donc qui
n'avez droit à rien dans la succession
il est vrai qu'il vivait avec lui donc
si lui et roanne dit vous voyez pas
chalencon pourquoi ne pas le croire
c'est tout ça moi je connais un peu
pierre-jean chalencon oseront des jeunes
on dîne soul de temps ensemble
il a peut-être des défauts mais c'est
pas un menteur noah il est sans fil
idées des conneries parce qu'ils sont
porte il est parfois outrageux etc
mais franchement c'est pas un menteur
bon et ça je pense qu'on peut se poser
vraiment une question mais je m'en fous
parce qu'on s'entend avec une fois père
jean salençon a dit et c'est vrai qu'il
était très aimé qu'l démente gilbert et
sur les réseaux on voit souvent des nets
gilbert ban ki moon
[Rires]